while more of those allegations of
Johnny Depp's drink and drug fueled
rages during which he is alleged to have
carried out violent violence and abuse
upon his ex-wife Amber Heard claims that
he strenuously denies we've heard a lot
about a particular incident in Australia
when he was there filming for one of the
Pirates of the Caribbean films during
that visit he and we were shown images
in court he dogged graffiti over mirrors
and walls inside rented house he was
using at the time using and he admits
this his own blood paint and some
lipstick that he admits as well using
his injured finger to do it remember
this is his severed middle finger that
he claims was an injury sustained by as
a result of the actions of his ex-wife
Amber Heard when she had thrown two
vodka bottles at him actually she said
that it was as a result of him
repeatedly hitting the wall with a
telephone which he denies a second event
effectively he did destroy the house the
lawyer for the Sun newspaper put this to
him the Amber Heard apparently came down
the next morning two televisions smashed
windows smashed and paint everywhere the
lawyer said to him as someone who was
sober and not under the influence of
drugs would have realized that would
have felt considerable pain he said he
knew exactly what he was doing and he
went on to admit for me at that time it
was the end I was convinced it was never
going to get any better
only worse and worse was death so this
the painting is a message to her good
luck and be careful at the top in
reference to her ambition to be a big
star he was also accused of drinking
during his filming during of Pirates of
the Caribbean and taking cocaine and
MDMA which he denies he was also accused
of pushing Amber Heard of spitting in
her face pushing up against a fridge
grabbing her throat telling her how
would be to crush her neck and also
throwing bottles repeatedly at a wall to
these accusations he said they were
fabricated ambitious he repeated what he
said yesterday in court that he believed
that this was a hoax by misheard that
she'd fabricated a dossier of untrue
evidence he said to get him and describe
him and to get him described as a wet
brain a savage and an uncontrollable
monster the trial continues